step into the realm of prompt
engineering a skill at the Forefront of
the AI Renaissance where words shape the
future in an era where an estimated 75%
of businesses are expected to use AI by
2025 mastering the art of prompt
crafting is not just an advantage it's a
necessity this tutorial is your gateway
to becoming an adapt prompt engineer
enhancing ai's Effectiveness by as much
as 50% % our journey will uncover the
secrets behind formulating prompts that
unlock ai's most sophisticated and
insightful responses designed for both
Tech Enthusiast and professionals this
guide deifies the complexities of AI
interactions you will learn to craft
prompts that are not just questions but
keys to unlocking ai's vast potential in
creativity analysis and Innovation and
before we move on just a quick info for
you if you are one of the aspiring
prompt engineer enthusiast or Ai and ml
Enthusiast looking for online training
and graduating from the best
universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers in prompt
engineering by learning from the experts
then try giving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in Ai and ml
Engineering in collaboration with P
University and IBM by enrolling in this
certification program you will gain
expertise in skills like generative AI
prompt engineering chat jpd explainable
AI machine learning algorithms
supervised and unsupervised learning
model training and optimization and
there's much more on the list with
hands-on experience and tools like Chad
j Dal python open CV and tense of flow
you will catch eye of the top recruiters
so what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll now a year of experience is
preferred to enroll in these courses you
can find the course Link in the
description box and pin comment so let's
get started without any further Ado so
first we'll see what is prompt
engineering so let's demony what prompt
engineering actually is in the simplest
terms it's the art Art and Science of
crafting inputs or prompts to
effectively communicate with AI models
like gbd3 Del and others it's about
being precise creative and strategic to
elicit the best possible responses but
why does it matter well with the right
prompt you can unlock the full potential
of AI from generating artistic
masterpieces to solving complex problem
let's break it down into the basics a
good prompt should be clear concise and
directed and you should avoid ambiguity
and and be as descriptive as necessary
remember you are guiding the AI to
understand exactly what you want here's
where the magic of prompt engineering
really comes into play by tweaking just
a few words you can dramatically change
the output as you dive deeper into
various instances and uses of prompt
engineering it becomes evident that a
prompt is composed of several key
components and now we'll see those
components a prompt may include any
combination of the following components
that is instruction a precise action or
directive you wish the model to execute
and then comes context that is
background information or supplementary
context that can guide the model towards
more accurate responses and then we have
input data the specific inquiry or data
for which you seek a response and then
comes output indicator the desired
structure or nature of the response not
all four components are necessary for
every prompt and their utilization
varies based on the specific task we
will explore more detailed examples in
the future tutorials so are you ready to
level up your prompt engineering skills
here are some Pro tips use specific and
detailed language experiment with
different phrasings and consider the
model's limitations and don't forget to
iterate the best prompt Engineers
constantly refine their prompts based on
the ai's responses all right it's time
to put Theory into practice I will walk
you through a live demonstration of
crafting prompts for different scenarios
watch closely as I adjust the wording
and structure to achieve the desired
outcomes feel free to follow along with
your own AI tool so here we will use the
chat gbt and that is the gbt 4 version
and before starting I want to tell you
that even experts make mistakes here are
some common pitfalls to avoid in prompt
engineering over complicating your
prompt being too vague or
misunderstanding the ai's capabilities
can lead to unexpected and sometimes
hilarious results learn from these
missteps to perfect your Technique
so now we'll start with the demo and
first we'll open our chat gbt so let's
start with the first prompt and we name
it as text condensation and refinement
so in this text condensation is a
critical skill that is used in natural
language processing and serving as a
broad spectrum of domains among the most
exciting applications for language
models is their ability to distill
complex models and complex articles and
Concepts into brief easy to understand
summaries let's dive into an enhanced
text condensation exercise using proms
suppose you are curious about the role
of antioxidants in the body you might
craft a prompt like this that I will
write summarize the role of
antioxidants so now let's see what rgbd
gives us the
output
so you can see that the chat jbd has
completed its response and like to
refine this information further you
might instruct the chat jpd or your
model to encapsulate the essence in a
shorter format so for that you can write
a prompt that use the above context and
summarize this into some 100 words or
some 200 words or just condense this
into a brief explanation so we will do
that so now you can see that the chat
GPT has taken our query or the prompt
and it has condensed the above content
into brief explanation so accordingly
you could use different prompts and now
we'll move to delay and we'll generate a
image and here we'll like we'll use the
condens format only to give a prompt to
Del so we'll write generate a highly
detailed image of a futuristic city
uh and we can specify what time of day
we want that at dusk and featuring
towering skyscrapers with glowing
windows or flying cars and a sky filled
with neon colored clouds so we can give
the prompt or generate prompt like that
only so we will write the prompt for
that that is detailed
image of a futuristic
City and here we'll specify the time for
the day uh that would be at dusk and
featuring towering
skyscrapers with glowing Windows flying
cars and what you need to specify you
could do
that
so let's see what Del respond to us and
you would see that it's repeat and you
could see that Dal is creating image now
with the prompt we
entered and this is the response so it
has given us that here are the images of
the futuristic city at dusk featuring
towering skyscrapers with glowing
Windows flying cars and a sky filled
with neon colored clouds you could see
the picture here so similarly you can
give prompts to DAL or any other AI tool
and you can get the output as expected
and you can iterate your prompts
according to the ai's capability ities
and now moving back to chat jpt so here
we will come to another type of prompt
that is information synthesis and
retrieval so these language models Excel
not only in language generation but also
in extracting and synthesizing
information from text so we will
consider this prompt that is designed to
pull specific details from a given
narrative so we'll ask it that
researchers often use various I tools
including llms like open a GPT in their
studies so I have a prompt return we'll
use that and let's see what chat
jpt gives the response for this
prompt so you could see here that
researchers often use various AI tools
including llms like open a GPT in the
studies of transparent disclosure of
these tools helps maintain Integrity in
specific publication so it's important
for authors to disclose the context and
extent of AA assistance in the research
and journals should be upfront about the
the a usage in the review process so
identify the specific llm that is large
language model mentioned in the text so
let's see if he can
guess so you could see that chat jbt has
given the response that the specific
language model llm mentioned in the text
is open a GPD
so so this was about the prompt
information synthesis and retrieval now
moving to the next prompt so on next
prompt here is enhanced query response
so optimizing how models respond to
queries involves crafting more intricate
prompts that guide the AI to deliver
precise and useful answers so for this
we'll write a prompt that would be
provide an answer based on the context
given so be sent and clear if uncertain
respond with cannot confirm so we'll
write the prompt for this and I have
written the prompt earlier so I'll show
you guys this is the prompt prom and
we'll ask jity about the enhanced query
response so we have pasted The Prompt
here and our prompt is provide an answer
based on the context given that is be
sent and clear if uncertain provide with
cannot confirm so our promp is here the
Innovative drug alab was developed as a
result of collaborative efforts between
several biotech firms so this drug aimed
that treating autoimmune disorders
represent a significant breakthrough in
biom medicine so we'll ask the chat
deputy
the question what is the purpose of
Aluma so let's see what it respond to
us so you could see that the chat J has
responded the purpose of Aluma is to
treat autoimmune disorders so this is
the type of prompt that is named as
enhanced query response so it optimizes
how models respond to queries involve
crafting more intricate prompts that
guide the AI to deliver precise and
useful answers so now we'll move to the
next type of prompt that is Advanced
text categorization so to handle more
complex task combining detailed
instructions with context and examples
can significantly enhance the model's
performance so here we will write the
prompt to assess the sentiment of the
following statements so we'll write some
statements and ask a chat GPD or AI
model to assess them and classify them
as negative positive or neutral so let's
see we'll write a prompt
here
assess the
sentiment of the following
statement as
positive
negative or
neutral and after this we will provide a
statement to chat
jpd so our statement would
be the move
movies stunning visuals or Shadow its
weak
storyline so let's see how CH gbt
classifies this statement as positive
negative or
neutral so you could see that the chj
has generated it respon
and it stated that the sentiment of this
statement the mov is stunning visuals or
Shadow its weak story line is mixed it
technologes a positive aspect that is
turning visuals and a negative one weak
storyline so you could see here that the
chat GPD can be used for sentiment
analysis so you could provide statements
and ask chity whether it's positive
neutral or negative now moving to the
next prompt so our next PR is dynamic
conversations so creating conversational
systems that adapt to very stones and
complexities is a fascinating
application of prompt engineering so
here's how you might design a system to
provide simplified friendly response so
for this we'll write a prompt and let's
see what UI model and our CH jbt will
give a response so this is a
conversation so here we'll write a
prompt and start a conversation with our
AI model so first we'll write hi there
what's your role so let's see what it
responds so as our AI model chat gbt it
states that hello my role is to assist
you by providing information answering
questions and helping with a wide range
of task how can I assist you today so
you can continue the conversation here
and we'll continue and ask him whether
you know about
photosynthesis if
yes kindly explain it to
me so you could see that our CH gyt has
started generating the response and it
has stated that yes I can explain
photosynthesis and it's a process used
by plants I gain certain BAC to convert
light energy usually from the Sun into
chemical energy
repeat usually from the Sun into
and it is giving us some examples you
could go through that and you can
continue your conversation with your AI
model so this is the another kind of
prompt now we'll move to the next prompt
type that is the Innovative code
generation so expanding on the potential
of llms that is large language models in
code generation let's explore a more
intricate example that is we'll ask them
to write a code for us so we'll write a
prompt that would be write a python
function that calculates the factorial
of a number and prints the result so
let's see what our CH jbt will respond
to
this
so you could see that chat jpt is
showing analyzing so it's analyzing a
statement and after that it will start
generating the code for
us and you could see
that it has generated the code and it
has the prompts or the statements that
explain the code itself so if you want
this code AS understandable you could
ask the chat J
to explain it line by
line and you could see that the chat jpt
has done the task for
you so you could see that it has
completed its response and it has
explained each line of the code with all
the necessity Concepts so moving now so
these enhanced prompts and examples
showcase how versatile and Powerful
language models can be and within well
structured and throughout instructions
as we continue to explore and experiment
with these prompts the potential for
creating sophisticated nuanced and
highly functional air driven
applications become increasingly
evident so these are the types of PRS
you could try on and with that we have
come to the end of this tutorial and
congratulations you have just taken a
big step towards mastering promt
engineering with practice and patience
you will be crafting prompts that bring
on the best in AI if you found this
tutorial informative and helpful then
give it a thumbs up thank you and keep
learning with simply learn staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry expert ERS choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here